yes real quick my wife has a swollen
foot she took a trip on a car trip to
Arizona from California and Arizona came
back and her foot was swollen she is on
some of our days youngevity projects and
by the way I want to give a testimony
real quick I also got on it youngevity
lost 45 pounds and I thank God for you
dr. Wallach thank you for changing my
life okay thank you okay so it's only
one foot this Wolin is it to put the
cheese on the gas and the breakers no
foot she was a passenger
it's her left foot she was a passenger
and we're just like wow what happened
okay okay here we go
does she have any history of respiratory
problems asthma bronchitis
she had thyroid issues and she was
having a hard time breathing months back
you know and okay okay we got it going
on here going yeah
does she have any skin issues and the
eczema dermatitis or psoriasis no do you
have any children with those problems no
we don't okay does your wife have any
bowel problems constipation diarrhea she
yeah diarrhea and she went gluten-free
like for the last couple months
but she that's kind of been an issue
with her often are you good are you
gluten-free
yes okay well you got to work on that I
mean it's got to be dropped at
gluten-free and what does she weigh 171
seven okay Charmaine what would you do
for to help her with that foot well got
it moments gotta go yeah well I guess I
would get her on to healthy brain and
heart packs and I would add some gluco
gel and I must sound for those issues
and what else from the Sun vitamin d3 I
mean III there you go Carlos
get going on those things and call us in
two weeks in four weeks in six weeks
we'll walk you guys through this but
thank you for the great testimony